Jim Nantz lead play-by-play voice of the
Masters the NFL on CBS NCAA Final Four
man he would have been busy this week
instead what's your schedule like you
know every day you come up with creative
ways to try to make it a little bit
different what it is and by the way
hello for hello friends and all friends
there are dances everyone it's it's a
constant living reminder of where I'm
supposed to be and it's a wonderful
thing people have good intentions about
it but it happens throughout the day or
I think once we get through Sunday and
the final day of the scheduled masters I
can go back to where every day I don't
get flooded with things that make me
live in the past it's difficult to live
in the present because I've went through
the NCAA tournament
virtually every day hey you would have
been going to the regionals this week
hey how how are things down at Atlanta
yuck-yuck-yuck for the Final Four
house one shining moment shaping up and
of course we've transitioned to already
today we out there for the honorary
starters this morning you know it's
where would you be right now and at
11:08 East Coast time where would you be
physically I would physically I would
have been on the ground since 7:15 ish
to make sure I was in place to watch
jacket Gary hit the ceremonial first
shot I've been going to Augusta since
1986 10 and I've never missed that
moment that ceremony going back to the
days of Sarah's and Nelson and Snead and
then of course Arnie with Jack and Gary
and now it's Jack and Gary and I've
never missed it I just love that moment
it's it's so heavy with nostalgia and
and paying tribute to the heritage of
the game and that's what a - Lee it's
one of my favorite things of the whole
year I get into things that people say
what are your favorite sporting events
is it calling this is it calling that I
love things like the NFL schedule
release those are my favorite kind of
sports shows the draft the NCAA bracket
release the opening tee shots at Augusta
those are my favorite things along the
way I'm not going to break out into
Julie Andrews for sound of music and
sing my favorite things but they are my
favorite things and I would have missed
that right now at 11:08 the the roundest
is well underway and who knows i
depending on who had a hot hand early i
might have walked out and saw someone
play late stages of their first nine or
even as maybe the first groups are
approaching Amen Corner we would have
been going through some meetings we
wouldn't have been coming on the air
with our with our partners from ESPN for
another three to four hours so lunch is
on the near horizon which is my one
chance to sit down and really kind of
catch up with Lance our great producers
through all these years where we kind of
start doing planning what we're going to
do the rest of the day but by the way
while you have me in the moment you have
me on the grounds there I've got the
late night show tonight so I will be
here so to speak since the 7:15 and will
be leaving the property closer to 11:30
ash after we finally see the late night
highlights shall know min and I loved
every minute of it you know I do I just
I'm just you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna have that sense every day of
Awareness Day of where we were supposed
to be and by the way maybe in here
somewhere
today I would be on the phone with you
anyway we normally we normally do
something about this well we do the Jim
Nantz sound alike contest which you're
gonna win because you're the unless we
move it to November and then I'm course
you will you know hello friends and then
dog woods and foliage which we normally
don't hear at Augusta can you drop
foliage for us in November I haven't
worked mentally on how that's gonna
sound or thought about the optics of
what that's going to look like I'm just
hopeful like everyone else that this
sports part of our universe which which
this country loves it's a rabid sports
nation I just hope that by the time the
new schedule for the Masters November
12th through the 15th we are well into
the sports world think back and
operational yeah and how about the fact
that there'll be a master
November and of course you'll circle
back around at five months later have a
second one so two and five months you're
going to be running a lot of sounded
like car which one I know it's tough
it's like choosing which child you like
best but which do you miss the most the
masters or the Final Four no it really
is it's it's impossible to say which one
you missed the most because it's
basically a very clever way dan I give
you major crops for that have asked me
which one I love them I was thinking and
I we've been down this road a few times
but I it really is difficult to not be
at Augusta right now now I lived through
all of March as I said I'm longing to be
wherever the site might have been
starting with the Big Ten Tournament I
got to do one game a regular-season game
at my alma mater which meant a lot to me
down at Houston is an unbelievable
chance to go back on campus but sitting
with Bill Raftery Grant Hill working
with Tracy Wolfson and our crew I love
it I love it what Augusta runs so deep
through my veins it's uh it's it was the
thing that most I think inspired me to
want to one day be in this industry as a
young kid just listening to the
storytelling and seeing the visuals that
came out of Augusta I was just crazy in
love with the event and that's all I
ever wanted to do since I was 11 years
old I wanted to work for CBS one day and
at that time if I was really being right
on the open about it III I was really
molded into into aspiring and broadcast
or pretending pretending because of the
wife CBS presented golf and the NFL I
loved the NFL coverage back in those
days and those two sports really had me
as it crazy obsessed CBS fan and I'm so
so thankful that I've had a chance for
my life to to somehow follow that path
that I could only dream of as a young
kid
CBS Sports announced its updated
programming for
Saturday April 11th Sunday April 12th
they will feature the final rounds of
the o4 and the 2019 masters tournaments
two classic tournaments featured
victories from Phil Mickelson and Tiger
Woods I heard that you spoke to both
Phil and Tiger recently would you talk
about we didn't speak we spent hours
actually taping each of their look backs
Phil will be on Saturday the 2004
rebroadcast of of Phil's first green
jacket and it was an amazing day I had
never looked back at that day of golf or
that broadcast I should say and Phil is
in maybe every third segment calling
golf with me for at time stretches of 15
minutes
maybe longer very generous both of them
with their time and it just exceptional
insight from them both and we were with
all day all yesterday morning with with
Tiger starting at 8 o'clock my time out
here in California and I'm on my
computer at Pebble Beach and Tiger was
on his at his home in Florida just like
Phil had been from his home down south
of me here in California and we just did
the whole zoom treatment with the
broadcast running at a center box on our
screen and we called golf and saying
thank Tiger this was not an interview
this was several hours of poring over
tiny little details about how it got
done key situational moments what were
you thinking and we're just following
along the broadcast feed dance so there
were no edits there's no later post at
it it's it's the broadcast speed with
the broadcast audio as an undercurrent
and what I thought was pretty amazing is
how both of them transitioned into like
the analyst role so smoothly so I could
be for example Tigers standing on the
tee at 12 which we all know last year's
tournament that was really the pivotal
point in the entire and final round for
the last six players hit it in the water
including the other two in his group
Molinari and vino so Tigers pondering
what to do
Francesco's already hit it in the water
playing with him and being up first then
there's a there's a cut to Zander
Shockley hitting his second shot he's
right in the mix he's hitting his second
shot at 13 so can I steer the commentary
let's go to 13 here Shockley now going
for the green in two and Tiger just went
right into some commentary about
Shockley skill and his ability and him
being in the mix and hearing the wars
from over at 13 actually it was it was
KJ Choi and Ernie Els who were who were
over at 13 and what was circling his
head because he heard the reaction from
from over at 13 and heard the roars cut
back to tiger shot at 12 move ahead to
Brooks koepka
over here at 14 can't Lee for birdie and
if we did this through the course of the
final round yes not every segment you're
amazing your machine now you are you are
that that's great so that'll be coming
up this weekend on Saturday and Sunday
are you in your office I am it's okay
can you do get a bad state right now can
you do me a favor been turned upside
down as I've been trying to turn into a
studio doing these zoom shows so I need
some unease some Syria I'm gonna have
the time though to reorganize what am I
looking for okay could you could you do
a submit you're gonna do you're gonna do
the nation a favor okay I need you to
get up I need you to go into the
backyard and turn on the augusta music
and that's problematic why you know why
I access it off my phone now I'm not
sure that I can yeah let me see if I can
okay
okay interesting can I do a phone call
and go to my Sonos I'm walking out of my
office okay out my front door okay
beautiful view by the way overcast will
thank your overcast day here a couple
here is so quiet
is I'm doing a scene we call this a
student stuff yes of course of course
yeah okay continue the word to stay the
skies are overcast as we welcome you to
the opening round of the Masters you
want to tradition unlike any other in
here absolutely and this tradition
unlike any other okay putting you on
speaker
okay here we go let's go to this app
this is really exciting and a little
nerve-wracking because I'm not sure I
can pull it off
okay just loading up okay do you got a
wedge there with you breathe a lot of
good what's that you got a wedge with
you I don't I don't get Jackson to go
get you one
Jamieson go get good I think of my son
go get Jameis so you're I are you a
little Jameis and uh is sleeping again
this morning okay all right so can we
didn't say says Wi-Fi isn't connected
fix it I think I might have been what a
shame this if I had given you a heads up
that might have helped you a bit all
over it yeah on already you know I blame
Fritzi I miss you guys up here you know
we never will shoot out so so Andrew
Mandy is the Glover that Opie is silver
champ I know I know Oh
well that's from you oh oh that's our
backup now I want to hear it from your
backyard that there's a difference in
backup in backyard Oh - I Jim's got
great sound system there are you I'm
starting to see some promise here okay
don't give up one no no never now I want
to give you a little jolt here as you
said we're doing this as a favor to the
nation yes okay so I'm gonna give you
instead if it comes out we'll start with
this and we'll end with the melody okay
okay let's see if this works okay come
on now it's it's it's our glassing pan
this is our one shining moment this this
will have to be a great substitute for I
had it all the way to the music cut
unable to play unable to play it says
never have that come up if it has to be
because I'm on the phone okay we're
gonna play the music and I'm gonna let
you act as if the Masters is happening
right now so I don't feel right about it
it's do you agree - just a little bit
we'll just try to do a little bit but
okay here we go I'm gonna do it under
the heading of this band we're
friends welcome the Thursday at the
Masters our hearts and thoughts go out
to all of you and I'm being a very
serious this has been the most
fascinating time or any of us in our
lives
we're going to get through this together
one step at a time
stay safe stay home stay healthy god
bless you all on this holy week and
we'll look forward to seeing you in
November there's golf applause I know
I've shut myself out of locked myself
and go back to my office you know we had
to deliver her message above all that's
in the heart because these are these are
the wildest craziest and there's just
you know it's really sad times but I do
want to bring back some optimism and
some hope that's what spring is all
about right there
you look it up spring is a season of
renewal it's all about hope and you got
Tony Romo back we never lost you but you
got him back yeah he went to the bank
he's still at the bank back and forth by
text every day I love the guy and he's
he's done sheltering with his home in
Dallas and yeah I'm so happy that that
all worked out we've got so many things
and listen there are so many people
right now know that are suffering and
it's it's why your show and to be able
to make people laugh a little bit and be
able to still have a place in the sport
universe is why it's so important
because you know you need you need
certain things to keep you uplifted so
that's where your role serves you keep
going on I mean I'm sitting here on the
sidelines I've got nowhere to go and I'm
making the most out of this situation
never in my life never my career ever
had this kind of time with my family and
we're aware how horrific it is to cleave
back in New York but all over the number
and thousands of people are affected by
it and you know we our family is you
know we're a prayerful Bunch and we're
really thinking everybody at this time
and it's just nice to be able to get on
the phone talk a little bit laugh a
little bit but I I do want to say this I
spend a lot of time watching and
listening and more importantly coming up
with my own conclusions on these data
spots data places that are making
projections and where we're going to go
where as what where is the peak when is
the flattening of the curve all these
things we've really learned about as a
nation and this is the tough weekend and
as you know this is like this is what
it's supposed to be at its peak in the
next few days you look at that data that
that Bill Gates funds at University of
Washington study and thankfully they
brought their numbers down their
projections significantly they've
adjusted twice in the last week and
again today's an amateur that's reading
this stuff and printing it out it's it's
really easy to go online and find it but
it you look at these curves and
everything and if we all keep doing what
we're doing it's really key we don't let
go of it now you stay at home stay away
from others keep the six-foot distance
when you have to go to the market all
these things that we're practicing if we
do this I can't speak to what this means
as far as rekindling the the sports
universe but I can't say this as a
society the numbers are going to drop
drop and drop significantly and fast and
we'll have a summer where it's our
hospitals are not going to be anywhere
close to what they have right now as far
as being populated
and we're at least going to have a
scratch I can't speak to the seasonality
of it but things are going to get better
soon that's my interpretation of what I
look at it the numbers and I'm hearing a
lot of these experts and I know love to
meet these these folks like Anthony foul
treated government Burks
who never get a day off and her time to
lead us through science they this is
these are the sites and the data that
they look at but it's it's it's a tough
time right now
but it's trending it's trending because
we're doing the right things in a very
positive way and I'm excited about that
I can't wait for all of us to be able to
go to our next chapter in our lives
dan it for you keep working did you get
back in the house I'm still trying to
find it opening the house is still
asleep
yeah well I'm wandering around my
driveway right now are you are you in
your role your pajamas wait what are you
doing
I'm already actually dressed for the day
showered and dressed and and ready to go
hey it's Thursday at the mansion you
think but I want to say this because I
think this is relatable for people we've
hit this pause button on on life all of
us never saw it coming and you know we
now got a sense of things that we kind
of rushed through maybe more than we had
in the past I mean I threw all the gloom
I feel so thankful to be able to have
this time with my my wife and kids and I
know a lot of people can relate to that
and maybe they're they're still crazy at
this point but you're going to have a
time in your life when you're going to
look back and say I got you know I got
to really play with my kids for a long
stretch and now as you again recalibrate
and you go back and figure out what you
want to do when you get back on the
treadmill of life
maybe we allocate our time in a little
better fashion and we did before we
don't rush through things and you know
that's that's what I'm going to do out
of all of us it's going to try my best
to figure out even more ways to cut
corners to stay at home a little longer
get back a little faster
these are things that are important to
my children because it were on the run
all the time you know and you know this
has been such a reality check for for us
as a nation and all citizens of the
world and we're gonna learn from this
well thanks for being a good sport
hopefully you get inside and call us if
you get bored Jim we're always here for
El Nino I I just the biggest bummer of
all is I couldn't play the speakers out
of the back I oh well I know we're gonna
tell but mr. Mike I could have done it
through my my wife's computer in the
kitchen yeah next time we'll rehearse no
I like it better raw like yeah I'm sure
you do here's the thing I Courtney's up
I'm all with I'm on with your great
friend Dan Patrick right now could you
because she says you make it like I'm so
lazy well reduce tonight all right we'll
tell Courtney I said hello and thanks
again Jim I was gonna play a super
computer but I didn't know how to get in
the house and now I have you've got to
go thanks I've got to go practice some
more music narration Thank You Gus to
melody on C a day at night it's Jim
Nantz